so in a previous video we're actually
covered the ten steps of the glycolytic
pathway
I mentioned that I talked a little bit
more about XO kinase and Luco kinase
later so here I am have to discuss the
similarities differences and the
importance of these two enzymes so
hexokinase equipo kinda to start by
mentioning that they are isozymes
I so meaning same designs referring to
enzymes now they're not the same enzyme
but they both catalyze the same reaction
okay so they both catalyze the first
reaction of glycolysis which converts
glucose into glucose 6-phosphate so you
see that there with hexiciah Nations
name over here with google kinase they
both catalyze that reaction okay so
what's the deal well let's start with
location so axial kinase is located in
all tissues whereas Google kinase is in
the liver and in pancreatic beta-cells
okay and that's actually important it's
functional and its purpose which we'll
get to later now one key difference is
there km's EXO kindness has a lower cam
which means that it has a higher
affinity for glucose which is it's it's
substrate right km and substrate
affinity R and inversely related
whereas bucco kinase has a higher km and
that's a lower affinity for glucose and
that's actually important too so what I
have right here basically shown in in
parentheses so the fact that have so
kinase is the lower km and a higher
affinity for glucose it binds to glucose
and catalyzes the reaction even at lower
substrate concentrations which allows
glucose 6-phosphate to be made even when
glucose levels are low okay so this
reaction will happen even if there's not
a lot of glucose around okay whereas
google kinase doesn't really do that it
has a higher km and a lower affinity for
glucose so it needs more glucose to be
around to catalyze the reaction so it
only works when glucose levels are
fairly high like for instance after a
carbohydrate rich meal okay and this is
actually important to its function which
we'll get to momentarily or
we'll talk about a minute also as far as
their v-max next Oh kinase is has a
lower v-max it doesn't work as as high a
maximum velocity and then as group of
kinase kinase catalyze reactions faster
now as far as allosteric control
hexokinase is allosteric be controlled
it's inhibited by the product glucose
6-phosphate
and so we could see that here g6p feeds
back negatively on hexokinase and
inhibits the activity so there's a
buildup of glucose 6-phosphate in the
cell then hexokinase will will basically
decrease its activity okay or Google
6-phosphate will cause hexokinase to DQ
set its activity whereas that's not
quite the case with Google kinases
there's a no allosteric control however
there is hormonal control there isn't
any hormonal control of hexokinase but
there is hormonal control of glucokinase
glucokinase has kind of kind of works
with and is associated with insulin
it's induced by insulin and induced
refers to basically transcription so
Google kinase trans the transcription of
the gene for a glucokinase is induced by
insulin so insulin causes more google
kinase to be expressed and that's kind
of what i'm showing here
it induces expression of google kinase
so when insulin is released more google
kinase is made and the still have more
google kinase activity
you